لكن في صدى فوزه بجائزه الكره الذهبيه
ولعبه المذهل في الملعب بدات الشائعه
تنتشر في خصوص رغبه رونالدو بالانتقال من
النادي اعلن ان نادي مانشستر سيتي الذي
كان تحت ملكيه جديده حينها يسعى الى شرائه
المال ليس معضله بالنسبه اليكم ماذا ان
اصبح رونالدو متاحا فهو يلعب حاليا مع
اكبر منافسيكم مانشستر يونايتد هل ستدفعون
70 او 80 او 100 مليون جنيه استرليني
مقابل سيتخذ هذا القرار بالاشتراك مع مدير
النادي مارك هيوز اذا اراد مدير النادي دم
رونالدو الى مانشستر سيتي
سنؤمن التمويل بين اسهم راس المال والفرق
هل ستدفعون 60 او 70 مليون جنيه استرليني
مقابل يعتمد الامر على استحقاقه للمبلغ
اذا كان يستحق سندفع لكن نفر رونالدو هذه
الشائعه سريعا حيث صرح انه لن يغادر ناديه
السؤال الاخير لي هل ستبقى مع مانشستر
يونايتد ام ان الشائعات عن مغازاتك صحيحه
في اعتقادك من سيلعب مع فريق مدريد العام
المقبل
ثم تحمق في هذا المكان اليس كذلك ظننتك
قلت متى كانوا في ناديه
ان اردتني ان اراهن على ذلك ساراهن جدا
على نفسي واعتقد انه اذا كان اللاعب
سيغادر اولد ترافورد ويغادر مانشستر واراد
الذهاب الى نادي افضل وهذا قابل للجدال
تمت خيار واحد وهو ريال مدريد وكان ذلك
مغريا جدا لدرجه ان رونالدو كان مهتما
بذلك
سعيت بشده للحصول على رونالدو وتقول انك
لم تعد تسعى للتوقيع معها هل تطمئن مشجعي
مانشستر يونايتد انك لن تسعى للحصول عليه
عندما يفتح باب الانتقال من جديد لا قلت
انك كريستيانو رونالدو قرر البقاء مع
مانشستر يونايتد وقرر ليونايتد الا يبيع
اللاعب وهذا كل شيء لا يمكننا فعل اي شيء
في خصوص ذلك
هذا يحصل مع لاعبينا ايضا ترغب نوادر اخرى
بالحصول على العديد من لاعبينا لكن يغلق
النقاش في حال لم يريدوا المغادره ولم نرد
البيع لم تعد تريد الحصول عليه اذا
نحن نرغب بالحصول على اي لاعب بارع في
العالم مثل ما يرغب مانشستر بالحصول على
اي لاعب بارع ليس فقط من ريال مدريد بل من
جميع ارجاء العالم ايضا لكن اعتقد ان
الاتفاق يجب ان يتم بين النادي واللاعب